the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
alright so now I'm going to walk you
through some examples and just so you
know where this stuff is so you all have
your ello grid accounts and in your
elegant accounts and I'm looking over
because these people are going to check
to make sure I don't say anything wrong
so this is by the way this is chance of
B on over here and Julie Mullen they are
our expert consultants PhDs and
computational science that help you all
and we're all externally grateful to
them for helping us get all this
technology to work so if you go to your
ela grid account those should be a link
in there called tools this is where all
the software is that we provide as part
of Illig Hritik exists and there'll be
one called d4m api in there so it'll be
a folder just like this ok and just so
you know so all the video all the
lectures are there for you and I am
putting them all in for public release
and all the software we're gonna post on
the internet too and so you know just
make it easy for you to use use with
your government use with your sponsors
using your projects all that kind of
stuff we try and do that so that people
aren't constantly asking us well what
can I share it's like we're gonna put on
the Internet
so there you go we want to focus on the
examples directory here the order of the
examples is numerical order so we are
going to go through examples in the
folder called 1 and then 2 and then 3
this really corresponds to kind of the
first three lectures then the next three
lectures in the next three lectures okay
and so today we're gonna go in here to
this first one and then here it's kind
of like the first three of those three
we're gonna go and we're gonna review
this set here okay so these are the
examples all have this sort of they
basically take the first two letters of
the folder in this case Assos intro ai 1
2 3 4 those are the actual examples if
you see other files in there those are
supporting
you don't run those directly so I'm not
going to start my mouth I'm gonna I
always run MATLAB from the shell other
people run from the IDE I'm gonna create
a shell here okay folder I'm gonna start
my MATLAB up this will take a minute
because we're using 2012 B which is a
little bit slower on this computer
alright there we go and you'll be
pleased to know I develop all the deform
software on this little computer and
people wonder well why don't you get a
big giant workstation to develop your
your program sounds like well cuz if
it's if it feels ok for me on this
computer I know that most of you have
much better computers and it will feel
should feel very very very good for you
alright so we're in the folder and I'm
just gonna run the first program III 1
set up tests look actually before we
even get into that the first thing you
want to do is check before you run this
that your d4m code has been properly set
up the simplest way to do that is when
you start MATLAB if you type help d4m
and you get a list of all the functions
in d4m and that means that your path is
is set up properly and this is just a
list of all the different functions we
break them down in different types and a
little sort of like how to set up here a
lot of this stuff isn't is written for
more people on the outside world and we
go through all the functions and we we
categorize the functions you know some
are functions that we really expect to
you you use all the time some are
functions as you might use you know once
you kind of rare Sims instances and we
also have functions like look you really
there they're there in the library these
are really not meant for you to use
though they're really internal
supporting functions but they're there
in the in the library alright so that's
the first thing you want to check is to
make sure
that's set up if you have any issues
send email to grid - help at LL done on
my TW and and the people will help you
and check it out and don't be surprised
if some of you do have an issue this is
the first time we've really rolled it
out to such a large audience and so we
absolutely expect people to have little
little things that will pop up all right
so I'm going to run the first example
here I should say we also have tested
all this stuff for those of you who are
utterly averse to commercial software
depending on your religious preferences
we also run with ganoub octave which is
the GPL version for those of you who
refuse to run non-free software and so
so this all the stuff should also work
with that as well just for those people
who prefer to use that type of
environment but generally MATLAB you
know it's pretty available here and so
we certainly encourage you to use that
so we're gonna run the first test here
one setup test go yeah it works
embarrassing when you're recording and
these don't work so I'm gonna walk you
through some really rudimentary stuff
here in this example so one of the
things in d4m that you're dealing with a
lot is lists of strings long lists of
strings millions of distinct strings now
matlab has data structures that do
support lists of strings cell arrays
being one of them and there's other data
structure that you can use to do that
they naturally support these but they
tend to be very memory intensive and
very slow and so given our whole thing
here is we have a real focus on
performance me giving you a great tool
that's a thousand times slower than
other techniques is not very helpful so
we are going to be dealing with lists of
strings all the time and so in d4m a
list of strings is a
row vector of characters okay I've
highlighted here and the last character
in the row vector is the delimiter in
this case it's the comma you're at the
end that is the delimiter it can be
whatever you want it to be can be a
semicolon it can be - give me a space I
tend to recommend new line which is
ASCII character 10 very safe delimiter
but whatever that last character is
that's that's the delimiter and you can
have different lists different strings
with different delimiters it should
handle those situations just fine
but but but within a list of strings it
you know it needs to be that that last
character will be the delimiter so I'm
actually creating here a a list I'm
going to be creating a set of triples
here R which is the rows C which is the
columns of V which is the values and so
I have an R which is this I have a set
of C here which is this vector here and
then a list of values and the values in
this case are just appending the row and
the column together with the dash and
all three of these use the comma as it's
the last character as the delimiter all
right and now I'm going to create an
associative array which is the
fundamental data structure in d4m it's
what allows us to bridge linear algebra
and strings together so this is the
constructor command for an associative
array so sews and then we give it a list
of row keys these are called milking Col
them keys list of column keys list of
string values and this constructs the
associative array a and in MATLAB since
I haven't terminated this with a
semicolon it now will print out the list
of triples so now you can see the list
of triples we can construct here was a
you know row a column a value a - a row
a a column a value a a - a and I won't
read the whole list
yes Darrell
that is an artifact of this printing out
just display it will show you the
delimiter that you actually used here
just as - and it's it's good to know
that you it's not really there well yeah
I mean it's there and it's not there but
it's showing you the delimiter and after
why you just kind of learned to ignore
that the only time this does become a
little bit of an issue is if that if
that is the newline character then the
formatting gets a little bit and we've
actually built in routines allow you to
take an associate of a replace the de
lunar with something nicer you know in
one command so that you can print it out
and doesn't look so so crazy if you're
using a newline typically though you
tend to be doing this print out command
on small things so it's it's fine so
that's the whole list you see there of
all the different entries if you use the
disp command it will actually display
the internal structure of the
associative array and an associative
array object in D form has four fields
total that's it
we do everything with just four fields
and the four fields are a set of row
keys this is a lexa graphically sorted
list of the unique row keys and it's
stored as a string lists so in this case
we had six unique row keys and we have
six entries in this row string list
likewise the column is the same thing we
have these six unique entries and you
see they inherit the delimiter that was
passed into them I've used different
ones you would see different de limiters
and then the then the value which is a
another list that shows all the
different strings okay and then a matrix
which shows which is a six by six matrix
so this is a six by six associative
array and this is the pointer basically
the
values stored in the 6x6 sparse matrix
points to the index of the value so you
can view that as a pointer to the values
and this is how we can have values that
are actually strings that may not be
quite clear there's an easier way to do
this so we have a little routing
function here called display full which
produces a nice tabular view of the data
so here's the row keys the column keys
and the values and you see this was a
the matrix that constructed you know had
a full first column and a full first row
and then values along the the diagonal
and then what we're going to do is what
we want to save this we want to write it
out so we're going to write it out - we
have a function Carol - also to see his
feet so he passed an associate array I
give it the the row terminator and the
column separator and a file name and
we'll write that data out to a CSV file
which is very convenient actually hide
that you can see here is the CSV file so
you can look at it there's the CSV file
we can zoom in on that for you
can you see there we go those are our
six rows six columns against first row
against the first column and our
diagonal okay back here now let's go on
to the next example which is going to be
a I too and now we're going to talk
about how we've sort of described how we
put data into an associative array we're
not going to talk about how we query it
or get data out of the associative array
and one of things that's very nice about
the queries that I will show you as we
get to the later parts of course we do
databases whether you're querying an
associative array that's in mayor memory
or a binding to a table it's the same we
try and make it so that almost
everything you would do on an
associative array you could also do in a
table so you can write your programs on
associative arrays and then switch a
couple things and now should also work
on tables in the database the same
Way and so we try and preserve that
concept the only difference is that a
table in a database is just can be much
much bigger than then a table then in an
associative array you would have in your
in your memory space all right so you're
gonna run that that's the next example
so the first thing we did is well we
wrote out the associative array we're
gonna read it back in so we have a nice
function here called read CSV that reads
CSV files just so you know Microsoft
Excel does write out a non-standard CSV
file Microsoft Excel almost the comment
that is if you have a row that is empty
after a certain point it won't write out
those commas which is technically
probably not conforming with the
official CSV format although I don't
know there is a sufficiently rich for
map right you can describe it in one
line so you just have to be careful
about that if you we see this issue
people right out of CSV from Excel and
if there's an empty last the last row is
not fully dense you know our last column
is not it's not a dense column you can
get this issue and it will scroll this
stuff up we also don't support quoted
strings the way to do that though is to
create a TSV file so put tabs in there
and we support tab just if you just call
this a TSV file when you write it out
you could have your separator be a tab
instead of column a comma and then
you're all good and so that's how we
support that so we're gonna now so
that's how we read it in and now we're
gonna do a whole bunch of different
queries these are all what are
relatively complicated queries so the
first one here is get me rows a and B so
if I pass in a string list just like the
goose you want to do that let's see we
pass in a string list of the same type
that I had before and I just say this
exact same type of indexing that we
normally have in MATLAB where you're
like I want to get
said arroz I give it us at a roast and
so this says get me rose a and B and
give me the whole rope : use the
standard MATLAB syntax that : means full
row likewise if a was a binding to a
table it would deliver the exact same
query to the database and return the
exact same thing in associated with
here's another more complicated query
that says give me all rows containing a
so our wildcard characters a little
liberal here it will just give you
anything containing an A it doesn't
really respect beginnings or endings or
anything like that it's kind of a
regular expression and then and this
says get any row containing a and
columns 1 through 3 so we can use
numerical indexes sometimes you just
like I don't care what the row keys or
just give me the first 10 columns for
the first 10 rows and that will that
will return this okay this is one
feature that does not work on all
databases some databases have a concept
of a numerical index of a column and
some databases do not so it's dependent
on the actual database here's another
one this is a range query so if you
remember in MATLAB if you do :
and two values it gives you a range so
we can do a range query here so a give
me all columns a through B if you really
wanted to just get do we have something
called a starts with which is something
like I a lot of times you're like I want
to just get the rows or the columns that
begin with a certain string so we have a
little shorthand routine here that
constructs that for you so this says get
me all row starting with a and C
likewise I can do the same thing with
columns I can say give me columns and B
I can say get me the give me all call
columns that contain a with columns with
rows one through three like I said I can
do column ranges here can say give me
all columns a to B likewise I can do the
starts with command as well it says give
me all columns starting with a or C
and then finally I think this is kind of
fun we can actually query the values
again this is a feature that's not in
supported with the database but is a
supported with the associative array
which is if I say get me all returned an
associative array where all the values
are greater than then B I'm sorry less
than B okay so let me just show you what
that one looks like so this was that
query and this is what it looks like so
I need to display a and you see now we
don't have any values that are begin
with a be all the values okay another
thing that we should notice here is that
this is now a three by three matrix not
a six by six matrix associative arrays
never store an empty row or an empty
column that is a big difference between
traditional sparse linear algebra and
associative arrays sparse linear algebra
you can have a row of all 0 of an empty
an empty row or an empty column not an
associative arrays associated race you
either have you know there's going to be
if you have a row or a column it's going
to have an entry yes so basically all it
does so it's LexA graph so it's
basically so if we had a value to begin
with see that would also not be included
so it's basically LexA graphically we
compare the value a a with B and we say
is it LexA graphically before B if so it
satisfies the condition yes yes so
that's the policy that we made so
strictly the algebra of associative
arrays doesn't require LexA graphical
ordering that's an implementation fact
it's a very important implementation
fact we are constantly maintaining
lexicographical order inside the data
structure yeah Darrell on this right
yeah 3 by 6 sorry 3 by 6 yes yes because
these are full here right but you see
that the ones you know this not it's
none of the ones with be in it
happening because they didn't satisfy
the record criteria so therefore they're
empty and so therefore so it's a very
important thing to know alright moving
on here to the next you define other
orderings the mathematics would no doubt
admit that it's really baked in though
into the implementation I mean ah
because we rely on the MATLAB sort
command and as far as I know that does
not allow you to have other orderings
now you could obviously do rehash you
can hash your rows and keys to some
other thing and then have an associative
array that maps those back and forth
effect people do that all the time and
just have you know and you could do that
but that's how you if you really really
want the order the main thing though is
to kind of think of it though is that
the ordering doesn't really matter it's
really a device allows me to do fast
look ups and you know you shouldn't
really care about the ordering all right
so let's move on to the next example so
actually a I agree so now we're gonna do
some math on this stuff okay
so here we go alright so once again I
read in my my data that I constructed
the first example the the values of that
data
we're strings but if I want to do math
sometimes I don't do want to do math on
strings sometimes I want to do math on
numbers so in in in d4m the associative
arrays can also be numbers which can be
very convenient for doing mathematical
operations and so what we have here is
we have this command called double Logie
which is just shorthand for and it's
kind of cut off here applying logical to
the associative array which takes all
the values and converts them just to a
zero one basically throws away the
strings or if it was a numeric value
just things maybe are you there you're a
one if you're not there you're a zero or
you're empty and then since we can't do
arithmetic on logicals in matlab we have
to bump them back into doubles so we do
this so often we've actually made a
little little shorthand here we call
double
you'll see that all the time in the
class because I just don't like to type
all the characters of writing double
logical it gets very redundant now if we
go and look at that data again we see
when you do display full that instead of
where before we had values of these
various strings we just now have numbers
just once
so that's convenient now I can do
arithmetic on them so let me do the
first thing here one of the things I
might want to do is sum all the rows so
the MATLAB sum command needs basically
you're giving it the essentially the
dimension to eliminate the first
dimension we want to eliminate or sum
over is is the row dimension so that
means it's summing up all these rows
it's basically squishing the matrix and
summing them up and now we have a new
associative array which is essentially a
1 by 6 associative array you see now
that the row key is empty because when
we sum the definitions of the rows sort
of kind of go away so we don't you don't
have to have strings to be your row keys
you can have numeric row keys just don't
just leave the row entry empty but there
are some cautions with that as well so
when we sum that and you see don't we
have all the columns the values because
they're not strings are just stored in
the in the this a matrix itself and you
see that we had six and two and two and
two and two and two so when we sum these
up that's exactly what you would expect
moving along we can do the columns so
here I'm going to sum and then I'm going
to do display full which is the same as
just kind of listing it and we see here
we now some the column sum to law some
compressed all the columns so we have a
column vector and it shows the row
labels of that column vector we now have
a new column label which is just one and
then you see the actual values there
again a very useful thing people we do
this all the time
summing of their rows and columns let's
do a simple join so I'm going to say
give me a column vector a get me another
column vector B alright now I'm going to
join these two together now I could just
do
a and a B but I'd get an empty matrix
the reason is because it would attempt
to do the joins and they would have
different column labels and so when we
do joins we're intersecting the two sets
of row and column Keys together and if
they have separate those are just
separate columns they you and them
together they have no intersection
however if we have this function called
no call which essentially blows away the
columns and basically give them all or
in this case a column value
why don't we can now add them together
when you can actually find where these
two things have a common value so that's
a fairly simple way to do a join um this
is something called a facet search which
basically says alright I'm going to join
these things together so I'm going to
create a column a column vector but then
I'm gonna transpose that over here so I
transpose it and then I'm gonna multiply
it back with the original matrix and
this gives me a count essentially of all
you know given all columns or all rows
that contained add an entry in column a
and B can you now sum up their rows and
this is a fairly this is actually the
mathematical basis of if you ever do in
Google search and does Auto buying it's
essentially trying to do this type of
operations trying to guess what the next
most popular topic would be and this
this essentially this mathematical
operation does that kind of thing we
actually have a bunch of applications
the lab that use this quite heavily and
I can display the transpose of that so
to make it a column vector and as you
see here we have a bunch of columns here
and then values and then we can actually
now do things like sum and normalize so
we can divide so I'm going to normalize
them and display that you see now you
get the probabilities associated with
these things just you know basically you
can just kind of go on your way doing
math this show it's essentially the
correlation of the columns a and B but
why not just do all the correlations at
once so if I'll focus on here so we have
this function square in which is the
same as a transpose a but a little bit
faster if you're just
something with itself I'm gonna get the
diagonal of that so if I use this
function adj it stands for adjacency it
will just pop out that a matrix by
itself we never use adj you're getting a
straight sparse MATLAB matrix and you
can do any operation on that that you
want that MATLAB support so it's really
weak highly recommend that if you can't
figure out how to do with the
associative razor just pop out that
adjacency matrix do whatever you want
and then you can just as long it didn't
change the size you can just stuff it
right back in at essentially no cost so
this just basically copies that field
out and we're going to get the diagonal
we just want to get the diagonals when
we do correlations we always get this
dense diagonal and won't eliminate that
so I'm gonna then now take the adjacency
matrix of the original correlation
matrix subtract the diagonal and then we
have this function put ad J which is
kind of the inverse of adj which just
says I have an associative array replace
that a with this no checking
instantaneous copy very fast but make
sure it's the right size if it's the
wrong size or you reorient it the
columns in some way or the rows in some
way then it won't make any sense so it's
a little bit of an advanced feature but
it's very powerful one you can pop stuff
in and out of these structures very
quickly and that way if you ever need to
do math that we don't support you can
just do that directly and so if we look
at that we see what you would expect a
nice correlation matrix here symmetric
with no diagonal and the counts of each
one right here so let me move on to the
next example here which is a i-4 and
this just shows you different ways to
construct associative arrays some of the
various kind of more degenerate cases so
I have a bench the items creating a
string here and a bunch of new very
numeric values the point here is when
you construct an associative array one
we have full support for all these
degenerate empty conditions you give me
anything within
kind of empty we're gonna return an
empty associative array MATLAB has
outstanding support for empty objects
you can just keep on passing you don't
have to we basically what I'm saying is
we do a lot of checking if the thing is
empty short-circuit return an empty type
of thing so you're not having to
constantly check if if something is
empty or not in order to proceed so so
that's what we do there that's just
showing it all it's all these supported
in addition you can do mixed types so
when you construct an associative array
if one of the values is a scalar like
for instance you can have that you don't
you know normally as in the MATLAB
sparse constructor when you give it a
set of triples they all have to be the
same length or any one of them can or
any of them can be scalars so this just
says I have a bunch of column strings a
bunch of numeric values oh and by the
way they all have the same row so this
is a very quick way to construct a row
vector I don't have to go and replicate
this a that many times to make this work
likewise here I could have a numeric
value for the actual rows string value
for the columns and I want everyone to
have the same value they're all going to
have a value of a and you can do
variations on that theme so you do these
are fast ways to to create row columns
row vectors or column vectors or values
with all a constant numeric value and
other types of things like that and then
we can just display one of these and you
see here I think it was which one we
displayed this first one which is a row
and you can see when you display that it
just has one value for the row these are
the different columns usually they're
values and again if we display full you
see in the tabular form that's what you
have so that brings us to the end of the
first lecture I'm happy to stay for
questions that people might have please
go and check out yellow grid account
copy the examples don't try and work out
of the you'll get like permission denied
errors and stuff like a copy the
examples to your home directory try and
get your d4m working try and run just
this first example make sure it
hey the same way that we had here and
then send email to grid - help and then
as we get into the next week we'll do
homeworks that are a little bit more
substantive but this is just to make
sure the technology is working for you
and that's that's we'll wrap it up there
thank you